in addition to citizenship rights
citizens also have responsibilities and
obligations
now obligations are those activities
that citizens must do or they'll face
legal repercussions but responsibilities
are activities that citizens should do
to be good and productive members of
society so you won't get in trouble with
the law if you don't do them but your
community will be a better place if you
do we'll talk more about the obligations
of citizenship in another video so for
now let's just focus on the
responsibilities
what are those responsibilities
first there's voting it's not legally
required that citizens vote in the
United States
unlike in some other countries where
citizens can get in trouble if they
don't vote but responsible citizens get
involved with the decision making
process through voting and to be a good
voter it's important that citizens are
informed they stay up-to-date on the
issues that government is facing and
they research candidates and ballot
measures before they vote but voting
isn't the only way to be a responsible
citizen you can also do so by voicing
your concerns for example something I
did recently and this is true was
emailing my city's transit department
about a streetlight that wasn't
functioning properly near where I live
the transit Department came out and
fixed it and now there's less of a
chance that an accident will happen in
that intersection so when you notice a
problem that may affect others it's
responsible to speak up and try to fix
things you can also act as a responsible
citizen by volunteering if you have a
skill to teach others or time to give
for a good cause you can make your
community a better place through your
service lastly good citizens respect the
rights and beliefs of others they
understand that in a democracy not
everyone may have the same opinions or
concern
as they do but everyone else is entitled
to the same rights as they are so that's
a quick rundown of the responsibilities
of citizenship which one do you think is
most important what other things can you
do to improve your community